when you interview people and you ask
them about their careers retrospectively
what most people will say is stuff just
happened to them right I was I was here
I was lucky they'll attribute it to all
sorts of things if you think about your
career and think about it broadly in
terms of what am i learning what's this
position doing for me how am I going to
get to the next one what's the most
important next move for me and you think
two or three moves ahead you can start
to you know put yourself in advantageous
positions to accelerate your career
disproportionately as opposed to sort of
creeping along the floor you can start
to sprint before you set out on your own
personal game theory you have to assess
your own playing field and who's on the
playing field does your boss want to be
known for creating talent and being in
that contributor of talent inside your
company or organization or does your
boss want to be known for really
delivering outstanding results because
although subtle it really matters for
you as an employee because if they want
to be a net contributor of talent
they're willing to rotate people through
positions coach mentor them and then if
you will set them free in other parts of
the organization if they're solely
focused on delivering results then what
they're going to do is over hire people
for the job and keep them in the job for
as long as they possibly can because
that's how you're going to deliver
results you're not going to take any
risk on people so you as a person
playing on that field needs to think
about what are your boss's motives and
what are they known for
there's only one job so you're competing
for that job with your peers and you
have to assess what are their strengths
what are they doing that's
disproportionate to what you're doing
and how do you position yourself to be
the best candidate for the next job so
you have to assess horizontally if you
will the peer playing field if they
choose you to go to the next job
do they have somebody to backfill have
you created a successor for yourself
because you if you haven't if you've
made yourself indispensable guess what
you're probably going to be
indispensable and therefore not moved so
you have to think about below are you
creating the conditions to make it easy
for you to move make it and allow your
boss to make that move with you
you